identifica el numerador y el denominador
en la fracción tres sobre cuatro o tres
cuartos vamos a reescribir esto en
grande para que se vea bonito y sea
mucho más sencillo trabajar tendremos
tres
sobre
y lo pensaremos de la siguiente manera
en este caso el numerador es el número
de arriba
en este caso el 3
mientras que el denominador lo podemos
reconocer como el número que está abajo
y está muy muy sencillo el número de
arriba es el numerador y el de abajo es
el denominador y esos nombres están muy
lindos pero qué significan cada uno si
nosotros tenemos una fracción por
ejemplo tres cuartos con el numerador 3
y el denominador 4 podemos pensar por
ejemplo en un pastel voy a dibujar un
pastel y tengo un pastel vamos a pensar
en un pastel cuadrado
este pastel está dividido en cuatro
porciones iguales
marcaré el naranja
porque son un total de cuatro porciones
eso nos representa el denominador el
total de partes iguales que tenemos
en este pastel tenemos cuatro las cuatro
partes son iguales y son el total que
tenemos y nos está diciendo que tenemos
un numerador tres o sea tres piezas de
ese pastel tienen algo en este caso
pensemos que nos los hemos comido puede
ser
no los hemos comido que son de chocolate
y la otra es de fresa vaya esto lo que
nos indica es distingue tres de esas
cuatro piezas tenemos 12
tres piezas pensemos que estas tres
piezas me las he comido si me dijeran
cuánto te comiste del pastel diré que
tres cuartos o sea una
piezas de las cuatro que habían si
pensamos en un pastel redondo vamos a
dibujar lo voy a hacer lo más redondo
posible
porque nos vemos que ese es mi pastel
redondo que me quedo muy redondo ok
pensemos que me quedo muy redondo ok
tenemos este pastel redondo lo dividir
en cuatro porque así me lo indica el
denominador tengo 4
totales de partes iguales y una vez más
marcaré tres de ellas que me las he
comido y entonces me he comido esta
parte 1
3 tenemos que esta también me la he
comido
vuelvo a marcar entonces que son una
y esto con base en el numerador entonces
tomando como resumen rápido el numerador
es el número que está arriba y el
denominador es el que está abajo el
denominador me indica en cuántas partes
iguales está dividido nuestro total
mientras el numerador me indica cuántas
de estas partes iguales utilizaré en ese
ejercicio específico